[Music]
[Laughter]
this show is brought to you by cash up
as you know cash up is the simplest way
to send and save money and now it's the
simplest way to grow your money
introducing cash app investing unlike
investing tools that only let you buy
entire shares of stock cash app lets you
instantly invest as little or as much as
you want
this way when your favorite company
stock is just a little too expensive you
can still own a piece with as little as
$1 and because cash app is directly
connected to your bank account there are
no four to five day waiting periods for
inbound transfers so you can start
investing today brokerage services are
provided by cash app investing a
subsidiary of square and member si PC
and as always when you sign up for cash
app and use the promo code Congrats not
only will you instantly receive $10 but
cash app will also now donate $10 to The
Trevor Project an amazing organization
that provides crisis intervention and
suicide prevention services to LGBTQ
youth across America download cash app
from the App Store or Google Play Store
today
[Music]
what's up guys it's me and it's episode
126 146 why did I say 26 I don't know
man I don't know who cares it doesn't
matter you'd listen it anyway
I could have said it was episode 19 yet
it kept listening because who cares what
number episode it is the only thing that
matters is that they keep on coming
mm-hmm let's see what's going on here I
have some tour coming up in Tampa
Florida well those are all sold out I
think Melbourne Florida I think that's
sold out Hollywood Florida
El Paso which there are still some
tickets left because who is in El Paso
I don't know Houston Texas and then
Chicago there at maneuv and then I got
Oh Willa Orillia Orillia Ontario January
18th days those just went on sale so I
don't know when those will sell out but
uh let's go and then Las Vegas next year
but yeah I'm back and I'm in my life
Rip's hoodie you can get those at
crystally accom just look at me like
this bro I'm [ __ ] comfy as [ __ ] soft
this [ __ ] cool this [ __ ] just kind of
hanging out having a good time and I'm
not even dude I'm so young it's crazy so
and you know when you look at me you
realize oh that guy's probably the
[ __ ] youngest guy I know and then
when you go home you're like nah he was
the youngest guy I've seen so cuz nobody
ain't nobody [ __ ] younger dude I
should have a sitcom where I'm doing the
[ __ ] and then that should be the thing
that everybody says at the same time or
they like cuz you know why and then
everyone says
ain't nobody younger and then we go
thank thank you everybody and then it
goes and then that's and then we stand
there it's not a freeze-frame but we
just stand there like we're frozen like
they did in what's that movie who knows
man all I know is
[Music]
but every time I do that if you like
we're morning and radio station here we
go we got the general main attraction
plane and it's he's not just Hawkeye um
so yeah I what wolves [ __ ] let me
break down the let me [ __ ] break down
this week dude you know I got no here's
the thing I I woke up today feeling
rested feeling good and thank God I shot
my special let me start with this dude I
shot my special uh Saturday now I don't
know what I'm gonna call it but I don't
think I've ever had a better taping you
know just the the the comedy all the
comedy [ __ ] that could go wrong it just
kind of aligned I was relaxed the first
show I went on my brother directed it my
first show I went on it was good really
good I got off stage and my agent was
like that's the best first show taping
I've ever seen and I was like really and
he was like yup and then I was like and
then I was like cool so we got to only
need pieces and when he needs pieces he
needs pieces that's all he needs so he's
relaxed dude so your boys relaxed now
you know the whole mantra of life rips
you realize you know what this is one of
those moments where life does actually
rep so the boy needs pieces and he's
going onstage for the second show and
he's seen his head he's like oh I only
need pieces and then he gets on stage
and as soon as he gets on stage dude he
realizes he only needs like two pieces
and that's when he [ __ ] just ripped
and that's when the [ __ ] ripped and in
the middle of the second show I thought
hey you know what I tapped [ __ ] I
tapped God on the shoulder and I go hey
God guess what we don't even need that
first show
so that second one was the Ripper man
that first show was ripping but that
second show was the Ripper so that was
just and I got offstage
and I go hey we don't need that first
show like I was [ __ ] the first show
was great but the second show made us
not need the first show so yeah it was
awesome dude it was it was so awesome so
happy I was so happy man had some loved
ones there was just happy man my brother
killed it and that's it I couldn't ask
for more
so I can't wait for you guys to see it
looks cool I had the Jordan the purple
retro ones on to help me pivot and let's
see I don't know what else to say about
it but I woke up that was the thing I
kept on like I as the days went up to I
was like I just I hope I don't get sick
that's the only thing that would [ __ ]
this up I've worked so hard to get this
[ __ ] goin to get the material sharpest
[ __ ] I did a 1011 day run before the
show I did some casinos coupled with
some theaters and I was like don't get
sick don't get chapped lips dude sure
enough the second I got off stage on
that second show my lips go like this
and just cracked now that's that's Jesus
Christ working with you that's Jesus
Christ just kind of it just kind of
handing you a couple of [ __ ] of a
sword a nut of his some assorted nuts
that's what he's doing
Jesus Christ just handing you some a
sword and assorted nuts now can I say
assorted nuts or can I only say a sword
and nuts and now that pisses me off
that it sounds like when I'm saying
assorted nuts it sounds like I'm saying
a sword and nuts okay but I mean
assorted nuts so that's like when you're
just kind of hungry walking through the
airport you don't know what to get and
Jesus Christ just walks up to you
and hands you some assorted nuts right
so that's what that was that was Jesus
Christ just kind of working with you
like you're in the cubicle and you type
in it maybe you're in a cubicle right
now and you're like I [ __ ] I need that
[ __ ] hey Susan can you hand me the [ __ ]
and Susan just reaches over the top of
the divider and hands Jesus [ __ ]
that's what's happening right now that's
Jesus Christ's hand aeneas some assorted
nuts as soon as I got off the second
stage my lip goes and I go doesn't
matter does it
no because when my lip cracks we know
baby's my lip cracks where it always
cracks and it's gonna you're gonna see
that on that high-def camera so I woke
up feeling good that day and I was ready
I flew from well I guess it's a Chicago
Airport too because I was in New Buffalo
Michigan for some reason and I went to a
job we drove to Chicago and we went to
the [ __ ] dude I got I took my tour
manager was with us cuz we were doing
like at a 10 11 day run Zach Danko vo
and that's how he laughs if you don't
remember and the guy is just the [ __ ]
worst tour manager of all time dude
straight up he's always the last one for
to the bus to the Sprinter van to the
airport he's like we're like I'm like
what the [ __ ] is Zach and my expect I
don't know man and then he shows up with
like just he always looks like he's
carrying 7 bags even though he's only
carrying like two bags and he's just
like oh I forgot my ID he's like one of
those [ __ ] that doesn't keep the ID
in the wallet you know those guys keep
your [ __ ] ID in your wallet don't
have your ID don't be the guy who comes
out and brings your ID and some cash you
know I'm talking about
and he'll be like I'm a wallet we're in
a casino we're staying in a casino we're
staying at the MGM Grand and in Detroit
and I'll be like let's go get a coffee
and it's in the casino and it'll be like
alright let's go and then I'll go down
the [ __ ] elevator and then we get to
the thing he's like oh you know what I
forgot my ID I look I'm 37
and she's like sweetheart I need the ID
and I'm like well I have it man you
should always have a [ __ ] ID on you
man and he was like well I don't know it
was in the bag because I had to because
this is my money and I don't know
so I I'm like I'm not waiting for you
bro
I'm gonna leave him at the [ __ ] hotel
one day I believe him at the hotel see
that telling is he's got some of my bags
sometimes so that's what's it I'm gonna
take all my bags one night and then I
get to the Sprinter van Zacks not gonna
be there I'm gonna say hey Mike where's
Zack he's gonna be like I don't know man
he was shuffling around in the hotel
room doing some [ __ ] he oh oh oh he
takes so long bro we could be in a green
room and I'll be like let's go
downstairs to see where the [ __ ] [ __ ]
is and we'll be like okay and I'll walk
down the hallway and I'll look I'll do
the thing where I will look behind to
the green room and he's still not out
yet dude I'm talking about you get out
of the green room and then you walk out
it's like when you leave a room and
you're waiting for somebody and you walk
down the hallway but you're still
looking at the rooms door and he's still
not there and you're all the way down
the hallway hey man get with it dude
always know where your ideas to do you
know why it's your ID if there's one
thing you should always have on you
besides pants have your ID on you my
podcast is musical my podcast is musical
that's probably why I don't like music
all that much dude but you saw your boy
when he used the mic when he was like
dance who other what other podcasts
[ __ ] host is doing that [ __ ] that's
because we are down for a silly goose
time and that's it and life rips now do
it I've been seeing people on Instagram
start podcasts talking about silly goose
times talking about how life's reps
talking about using my cadence and
that's fine dude because people know
where you got it from and it's all gravy
okay but just so you know we all know
and that's fine rep the cult do it
whatever sometimes people use it and
they're disgusting with it sometimes
people use the way I talk and they start
talking about blumpkins or something
that we don't do that dude we don't talk
about blumpkins here at the [ __ ] log
cabin I'm a classy guy I'm a classic man
what's that [ __ ] song no fun either
tonight I'm a classic man anyway dude we
don't talk about blumpkins man we don't
talk about gross [ __ ] you know maybe I
might mention you should take some
Metamucil if you're trying to you know
take some nice bowel movements but I
don't talk about blumpkins I don't talk
about [ __ ] you know [ __ ] that much
and I don't I don't I would never say
something like grundle you know that
mean like I'm not a [ __ ] frat guy how
many the guy who goes like this the guy
who talks about a grundle is a guy who
goes like this when something's funny
the whole man that's classic that guy
says grundles so much and I don't do
that [ __ ] you know how I go man you know
how I [ __ ] go all I want you know
what I realized man when I was coming up
in the [ __ ] comedy world like
whatever my my brother and I we have
this way of talking and it you know my
friends we all have it and I was like
hey I want to do I I wish the world knew
my language now baby I made the podcast
another world most of my language okay I
did it I didn't know I could do it but I
did it if you build it they will come
but I woke up feeling so [ __ ] good I
woke up feeling so good three days
before my special I woke up feeling
shitty two days before my special and
the day I am i special I woke up feeling
good now I got a question for you
scientists why does it happen how come
sometimes you get lots of sleep you feel
good sometimes you get lots of sleep you
feel bad sometimes you get a little
sleep you feel good sometimes you get a
little sleep you feel bad what's the
deal why do I see better in hotel beds
then I do it in my own bed what's the
deal do I need a new mattress maybe but
mattresses are thousands of dollars so
that's a little bit weird for a [ __ ]
test of something to be a thousand two
thousand dollars how much is a mattress
I don't know I'm so [ __ ] at it I
don't give a [ __ ] how much is a carton
of milk forty five dollars I'll cough on
you [ __ ] too but yeah it's you
know it's it is what it is man but I had
a good [ __ ] special taping and it was
awesome and I woke up feeling so good
and my buddy Mike went on before me and
he was like don't whoa dude there were
no Woo's on my last special there were
Woo's bro
I [ __ ] hate when people go you're not
at the Nets game why are you going woo
dikembe mutombo is an on-stage and
yeah dude hey why go and woo Jay Buhner
is it out on this field and so yeah it
really pissed me off when they go woo
and they were there was no Woo's there
think there was one rule on the second
show somebody got kicked thrown out
apparently imagine being that big of a
now so he was talking loud I'm a manager
walked out to him he was daring as I
kinda throw someone out look and there's
my out you know I think I was like he
was I was like what happened he was like
he was just being loud okay he got up
led to the bathroom Leon I suppose dude
I think him back it was like where's my
seat us there game exists being really
alright you know so I did from out and
he was like well can I just go back to
my yeah and I was like sure well your
staff is hold on you know and there's
like where is it it was like well look I
don't know I got a wallet my ID in there
you know and I got at anyway we've come
out he's been loud go got scary mom so
and you know it's gonna work out you
know and I knew it nice arse like he's
gonna be fine okay but and and so he
threw him out dude
he's a bulldog man my managers good Josh
Lieberman and somebody tossed him out it
was all good didn't really hear it he
kind of [ __ ] he said so I think I
heard something the first show I think
it might have heard him get a little
loud - the first show but how could you
be that [ __ ] he I did not egotistical
but self sent her to be like making a
scene at the [ __ ] Netflix special
taping anyway um yeah so laughing don't
laugh like I always say they're trying
to get rid of [ __ ] how about the lady
that was on what was it Good Morning
America or no it was a British show
right how do I pull that up where she
was trying to get rid of clapping get
banning clapping good morning Britain
Spacek good morning Britain so basic or
morning good morning why can't I [ __ ]
say it dude Brit Ain there we go should
we ban clapping good morning Britain
it's victorious the Sun let's take the
serious side of this first what is
upsetting genuinely about clapping okay
nothing there you go and there what is
something about clapping nothing and
thank you a word from our sponsors
that's how I should have ended right
there and then that right here this I
should've been the serious first what is
upsetting genuinely about clapping
nothing nothing at all
absolutely nothing that's how it away
let's take the serious I wanna do it
again some annoying what is upsetting
genuinely about clapping well absolutely
nothing
[ __ ] that's funny dude anyway so this is
what is upsetting your sobriety
oh so mad already so it's actually not
just people anxiety people who use
hearing aids coughing can be disruptive
to that it's also people who use hearing
aids clapping can be disruptive to that
people who have sensory processing
issues it can be very distressing you
know overwhelming to have those loud
sudden noises but it is a great part of
our culture hey let's just go let's just
so far I agree with both of them let's
see how it derails look at this look at
how look I love when people try to be
diplomatic about about something but
it's impossible to make them not sound
like it does not feel like an idiot why
it's a bit like part of it like the
culture right when we go to the theater
you're going to expect to hear clapping
right now I don't mean that you're a
piece of [ __ ] when I say that but it's
literally it's virtually impossible for
me to not make you seem like a piece of
[ __ ] right because I'm saying something
that's so [ __ ] obvious you're not
mine anyway go ahead expand on that
culture or you go to a lecture or you go
to a performance or you go to a gig you
would expect that people would clap yeah
absolutely and that could be preventing
people from going to those events so far
I agree with both of them
and we're you know 37 seconds in and and
your boy agrees with both of them dude
so this is great man which is a real
shame so if somebody okay or not and
that could be preventing people from
going to those events okay a group other
one which the real shame I picked the
side I booked the side through some
theatres or some universities I took a
step on over to the other side but
took a step okay maybe I got another
foot I'm like we'll see what this other
lady has to say let's see more what this
lady has they maybe I'll call back
do you know what I'm saying we'll see
only I'm leaning over into that foot
jazz hands instead and just like that
I'm on an escalator in a full sprint
when you say jazz hands you lose the
argument it doesn't matter if the
argument is for jazz hands it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter if the debate
is called the jazz hands debate as soon
as you say jazz hands
yellows okay let's just go back and let
me not in a rough spot people would clap
yeah absolutely and that could be
preventing people from going to those
events which is a real shame so if some
theaters or some universities say
actually we can be more inclusive and do
jazz hands instead I hope you lovely
people could get involved and then what
would oh wow did you hear the guy the
other guy who just oh my god that was
amazing I never heard that yet someone
is stupid okay
oh gosh oh gosh okay
and dude jazz Hanson said that'd be
lovely other people could get involved
and then oh oh by oh just hurt himself
literally when she said that she said he
goes oh oh oh oh okay it's going to be
okay I just have to breathe I hope I die
before this actually implements not see
if you clapped I don't think there's
going to be that that's great and then
what would be the penalty if you clap
what if she just said tasers tasers and
we throw baloney at your face I don't
think there's gonna be a penalty frankly
I don't think anyone's going to say like
no I like how that lady came back in and
like was kind of like listen
not gonna be there okay it's not gonna
be you know I like how that I like how
she's arguing she's arguing for the
wrong thing and we all know we're but if
you the guy came in again but yeah of
course they're not going to persist in
with clapping even though you've been
requested to do something that's not
very polite is that like I think people
understand if you're requested to do
something in a specific context
you can do it would it stop you and if
you were somewhere and you felt the urge
to clap someone yet they'd said we don't
clap here that guy dude well every
[ __ ] syllable he said was the same
note that guy was unreal I'm not even
talking about the [ __ ] thing anymore
the clapping and not clapping that guy
was so angry that he was trying to
control his voice with what and he did
it too hard the other way it was
everything was one note one note people
understand if you're requested to do
something in a specific context you can
do it with it I'm so mad okay let's just
calm down let's not try to get a rise up
my voice let's be let's do this come on
Nigel stop you and if you were somewhere
and you felt the urge to clap someone
yet they'd said we don't clap here what
if you weren't somewhere and someone put
the end to crap and then someone said we
don't clap here and then it says like
you did it no Joe well they wouldn't but
what we don't do is completely
restructure society and completely
change societal norms in order to
accommodate the sensibilities of a few
people it's interesting just reading a
story about this on on the BBC News
website a individual called Hannah from
Weymouth in Dorset does she struggles
with loud noises like clapping talk she
was diagnosed with autism and she was 23
she says I don't agree with a ban on
clapping instead let's raise awareness
of autism because this could breed
resentment if other students start to
harbor bad feelings towards autistic
that's smart she's real smart so listen
okay
banning what okay I got to Minneapolis
and I went into a pub or a bar whatever
the [ __ ] it was and when I got there I
had to get something to eat
it was like 2:30 I wanted to eat at 2:30
because I didn't want to have to eat
right before my special taping because I
would have been on the mic just like so
anyway you know that's what happens you
just like yeah so what's the deal with
anyway so I ate at the right time and
when I was there I was in a [ __ ]
place and there was a really big local
you know football game that was playing
now did it make me mad that it wasn't a
professional team even yes you know but
it wasn't so were they were there old
men cheering for [ __ ] you know
19-year olds on a field throwing a ball
around yes did that make me feel like
life was hopeless yes is it all right
sure
because life rips regardless so I was
there I ordered a turkey club you know
how we do I like to keep it fresh even
though that's what I I get a lot I
hadn't I got it for a long time
so I got the turkey club and it was like
this can be the great thing before I the
meal before my middle for my special
right so this football game was going on
people watching it I step in I sit down
i order as soon as I start ordering
people are [ __ ] fogers
and screaming now did that make me Mady
yes did I feel it in my heart of course
did my chest tighten up yes was I trying
to do everything I could from getting
into a bad mood yes did I somehow open
the door on the bad mood yeah I did then
did I think oh [ __ ] I don't want to be
in a bad mood while I'm taping my
special
so let's calm down now these are all the
things that are going on in my head
while these [ __ ] [ __ ] are just
having a good time watching the football
game right they're screaming now I
didn't did I mention that got that the
guys screaming at the TV also were in
tail coats and top hats
did I mention it well they were I don't
know why were there two guys dressed the
same yeah well I guess they were [ __ ]
working for the hotel or some other
hotel or some [ __ ] I have no idea but
they were so loud screaming at the
[ __ ] team and other people were like
what the [ __ ] is going on now I got I
got mad and I was genuinely thinking am
i one of these [ __ ] people that can't
stand clapping and then I thought well
no I'm not but if I was I would just
stay home or go and deal with it people
like this are just never gonna that's
not gonna happen
what are they saying that this is what
they want they're like well we think you
know people should literally it's like
dirt
why don't they just get rid of their
arms you know on all honesty I think
that it would be a better society if
they get rid of their arms you know this
way they don't have to they can't clap
right and then people can go you bend it
too far one way and but by the way this
this just made probably I don't know how
big it is 55,000 people saw this are the
good morning Britain show so out of
55,000 I would say it probably made
maybe 150 people sway their vote to
Trump you know so I just I mean so
[ __ ] silly and then I looked on the
girls Twitter and she was like well I'm
getting properly dragged aren't I yeah
you're getting properly dragged British
me undies hey guys it's officially the
holidays and people are already shopping
for gifts before you freak out about
what to get your boyfriend who you've
only been dating for four months or what
to get your mail man I don't even know
is that if that's the thing that's on
this type right here but I don't know if
that's a thing or the fact that I have
to go to the mall which nobody likes
doing anymore don't tell them all listen
up me undies is anything but ordinary
they have a gift for literally everyone
yes including even your weirdo whoever
it is uncle or aunt whatever I have a
weirdo uncle but the best part is that
they deliver straight to your door with
free shipping that's a holiday miracle
right there dude they have all of the
different they have so many different
patterns and stuff it's great I get me
undies all the time
I have the different I have the ones I
like I liked a lot of the solid ones and
some of the some of the pattern ones
patterned ones I've launched with dinos
on him when I'm feeling funky but you
can get all these on there and if say
your best friend you don't know what to
get him but he loves dinosaurs they have
that if he loves this and that he loves
arcade games then you go they have ones
with arcade games on them like I have
those too
so go look at the website speaking of
not wanting to live in the house
biondi's makes the perfect hibernation
on these and loungewear whether you're
looking at match on these with your boo
this this season you can do that the
fabrics three times softer than cotton
and they have extra small to 4 XL three
times softer than cotton it's it's just
great immunity's has a great offer for
my listeners for any first-time
purchasers you get 15% off and free
shipping this is a no-brainer especially
because they have a 100% satisfaction
guaranteed to get you 15% off your first
pair free shipping and 100% satisfaction
guarantee go to me undies comm /
Congrats that's me Indies comm /
Congrats manscaped support for crank
congratulations comes from manscaped who
is number one in men's below-the-belt
grooming manscaped offers precision
engineered tools for your family jewels
it rhymes position boom swinging family
jewels I Nick my balls all the time but
not with manscape I have nickman balls
so hard that the blade don't like that
because then your underwear gets all
bloody all good manscape limits that
they redesigned the electric trimmer the
lawnmower 2.0 has proprietary skin safe
technology that is trimmer won't Nick or
snagging nuts it also has a crop
preserver anti chafing ball deodorant
and moisturizer you put deodorant your
armpit why wouldn't you put it in your
balls
okay right exactly put it on the I mean
it's a it's a great part for you to
smell good as your balls in case you get
lucky you never know always use the
right tools for the job and your balls
will go like this ah they'll thank you
get 20% off free shipping and a free
travel bag with the code congrats at
manscaped comm that's 20% off with free
shipping and a free travel bag travel
travel bag at manscaped calm and use
code Congrats dude check this out life
rips but guess what under it all life
rips as well so not only do I have the
live room hoodie on I also get the life
ripped shirt on because life rips
whether you [ __ ] no matter what layer
you got on and that's not even a
commercial that's the truth
Wow Wow um I'm having a good time I'm
having a good time I'm checking text cuz
I got to be respectful on you do it I
can't not be me the real meat checks his
texts
and when you come to this podcast you
get the real me the real me sometimes
[ __ ] roll the sleeves up it gets
[ __ ] gully that's what he does do it
don't know what it means know that I
[ __ ] hear uh Taye Diggs say it and a
movie yeah some gang golly nobody could
stop me on that I work in a [ __ ]
workout a [ __ ] workout and I push it
to the limit do it I really do push it
to the limit especially when I got my
trainer rock oh dude I push it to the
[ __ ] limit I sincerely push it to the
[ __ ] limit I did legs yesterday do
you understand me I [ __ ] did squats I
did split squats I did zombie lunges
like and I did [ __ ] those but ones
were you [ __ ] I don't know what it is
but you put the bar over your your your
your penis and then you [ __ ] thrust
upwards bro and it hurts your dick
sometimes but I [ __ ] went through it
I go I go downtown I go downtown I take
my hand I put it downtown under the
fabric I fixed my penis because if I
don't do that then my penis gets [ __ ]
rocked by the 45 pound bar you can't get
your penis rocked by the 40 film buck
for the farm pound bar anyway dude rough
and rugged unpolished in hardcore that's
me to the gully me and Taye Diggs Taye
Diggs goes to my gym by the way shut up
butters Earl in cell and me so yeah so
dude I [ __ ] worked out so hard my
legs are so sore and I'm gonna do chest
today and I'm gonna do back today dude
I'm gonna walk around like a goddamn
turtle dude people see me they're like
is that [ __ ] Chris D'Elia or to
Turtles Haugen cuz this backs like that
and this fronts like that dude is he
coming or going is that two turtles
hogging what the [ __ ]
is that the leer or two turtles hug and
dude I don't know man I don't know if
it's a door if there's filming [ __ ]
they're filming The Hobbit because I
swear I see a camera crew on those
[ __ ] mountains dude if you listen
closely if you listen closer to my back
you can hear Jake Gyllenhaal say I can't
quit you because that's um that's an
open range dude um anyway yeah I woke up
feeling good today god Zach always
forgets his idea it's not so annoying I
got I'm gonna take a break though dude
I'm not even going up this week how
about that dude I've never done that I
never called in for I never not I never
didn't call in for spots for a whole
week in LA and I'm doing it now and I'm
doing it now because I deserve it and I
deserve to kick back and relax and lay
my feet and just [ __ ] understand that
I'm gonna be stretched out like a tall
drink of water the whole time okay um I
need to start doing the figure I saw
Kevin Hart came back and he could you
know how man that guy works [ __ ] hard
as [ __ ] everything with that guy's a
movie he came back and he's like you
know sometimes you have to do this to do
that you know he's one of those guys
that always says does that kind of thing
well sometimes you got to do this to do
that sometimes you got to do that to
realize this you know and that's what
happens
but he's the hardest-working
[ __ ] dude even when that guys
thank somebody that guy who posted the
Instagram of an Instagram of his family
on vacation and it still looks like it's
work he's like I feel like that's how he
goes on vacation he's just like this how
we gonna do it alright we're going this
way we're going come on get in the car
get in the car we'll go to the airport
we got this we got this we got to make
this happen
come on come on but my family and then
he's in the jump in a bowl come on here
we go get on the suits we're doing this
we got this man jump in there we go we
are having fun that's how it feel like
Kevin Hart does vacation cuz he came
bare because I feel like he convinces
himself that it's part of something that
he has to do to make his work better
because that guy works so hard
we're notion now you have fun get in are
you having fun yes good this is part of
life and after this we're gonna go to a
nice dinner do you understand eat it do
you like that
hell yeah because we have a good time
because this is what life is about
eat it have a good time do you want
dessert yes and don't I feel like that's
what he's like he's working even on
vacation this is good this is good for
our family do you understand this is
good for our family we are building we
are building so yeah so mmm it's just
all sorts of [ __ ] man there's a lot of
stuff that happened this week though how
about [ __ ] Matthew McConaughey on
Instagram did you see this speaking at
Instagram okay okay okay I mean dude you
know you you know I talk I think I
talked about Garth Brooks on the [ __ ]
I know Segura talks about with Cristina
a lot on their thing about Garth Brooks
but I mean that [ __ ] it's just a way I
am this is another Garth Brooks I don't
it's funny man these guys get so famous
and I I think man he's [ __ ] awesome
you know III [ __ ] love him he's a
great actor seems like a cool guy seems
like he loves being a guy's guy seems
like he fancies himself that way like
he's just like hey man I know I'm [ __ ]
an Oscar winner but you know me you know
me be hard-pressed not to find me out in
an open field somewhere with some tall
grass you know yeah man that just me I
drink I drink beer that's me
him and Jason Momoa like if they hung
out together it would be like the two
[ __ ] most guy iasts guys that like
would try to be proven that they're the
most guy iasts guys Jason Momoa would be
like well you know I have an axe and
McConaughey be like yeah man that's
funny I have an axe too
I have a few axes actually I'm a mole be
like no but I made mine and and and
McConaughey be like yeah
yeah that's funny man yeah I remember
making my axes in the 80s and I made
what was it I made a bow and arrow to go
hunt because we eat we eat whatever we
kill yeah I haven't eaten a meal
store-bought it's been since the 80s and
then moas like yeah I was born I was
when I was born but I don't think I've
ever eaten a store-bought meal actually
I remember when I was three my first
word was let's kill something and eat it
McConaughey's like yeah yeah I remember
that I remember that I was there you
didn't say that did you
no you weren't there because it's in
this remote area and then he cuts them
off he's like yeah that remote area in
that island that we just build
everything anyone see see me okay here
we go we'll keep it going my page I
wanted to see see me um look this is my
first venture into sharing myself and my
views with the world and I'm a little
bit nervous about it
because quite frankly I'm like I know I
won't have a monologue I'm not sure I
won't have the dialogue but
first of all what's this [ __ ] thing
that white really white successful
famous like actors get where they're
it's like they say some [ __ ] and just so
many people have been guessing them that
they'll do some should say some [ __ ] and
just how laughter it like Tom Cruise in
the [ __ ] Oprah thing like Tom Cruise
is there Matthew McConaughey is there
like movie stars get their you know
they'll just be like you guys hungry and
they'll be like yeah yeah look what do
you want to eat I'm like I don't know
maybe yeah maybe a chicken or something
[Laughter]
and they're like oh man he's so regular
that's what Zach Tokyo doesn't he's not
even famous he laughs at everything
did it learn that you got to have the
dialogue to have the monologue just as
you have to have a monologue to have the
dialogue [ __ ] absolutely it's a
philosopher Oh [ __ ] come forward to
it I'm looking forward to sharing Who I
am with you I'm looking forward to
seeing it for if Who I am translates its
what I want to share translates if it
tickles your funny bone it makes you
think a second makes your heart swell up
a little bit if it makes you take a
quiet moment for a walk go I gotta check
in with em and uh hopefully does that
syncs with the me some fun with it
though whoa dude check in with em in the
e oh I'm s that's your dad right there
you'd be like dad don't say the M in the
e just save me home for [ __ ] sake dude
made me make someone check in with them
and ate oh wow so funny man that's again
let's keep the heii that's low aye aye
aye
oh that was it when people got on my
page here we don't want them to see see
me look this is my first venture into
sharing myself in my views with the
world and I'm a little bit nervous about
the whole thing because quite frankly
I'm like I know I won't have a monologue
I'm not sure I won't have the dialogue
I'm her stalker but I've learned that
you got to have the dialogue to have the
monologue just as you have to have them
all along to have the dialogue so I'm
looking forward to I'm looking forward
to sharing Who I am with you I'm looking
forward to seeing it for if Who I am
translates if what I want to share
translates if it tickles your funny bone
it makes you think a second makes your
heart swell up a little bit if it makes
you take a quiet moment for a walk go I
gotta check in with the M and the e oh
hopefully all those things let's have
some fun with it though and let's again
let's keep the high I that's low aye aye
aye what does that mean the high I when
people God is that God he's out to lunch
huh
he is just eating lunch during that time
look at the people who comment the Texas
football course they did I mean okay
Vanessa Hudgens into it she says is that
the girl that the young actress girl I'm
an idiot yeah that course is the rock
welcome to the gram and happy birthday
my brother you know how we do it
all offense okay well Lincoln commented
with the convert-a-car
welcome to Instagram official method
McConaughey Fisher McConaughey we think
you'll enjoy the ride okay Reese
Witherspoon Roger Clemens Jessica
Chastain it's so funny do these people
like I see people
I'd like like I say he's amazing
but [ __ ] that's funny Garth
Brooks shot that oh my god makes me want
to check in with the M and the e you
mean me so [ __ ] rockin okay butcher
box when it comes to meat quality
matters okay but there's more to it than
texture and taste low quality meat can
mean low quality flavor the good quality
meat the kind of get from butcher and
from butcher box is better for you
the animals and the environment period
luckily there's butcher box butcher box
believes everyone deserves high-quality
humanely sourced me every month butcher
box ships a curated selection of high
quality meat right to my home all meat
is free of antibiotics and no added
hormones each box has nine to eleven
pounds of meat enough for 24 individual
meals it's all packed fresh in ship and
shipped frozen and vacuum seals so it
stays that way I can customize my box
would go with one of theirs it's really
cool
butcher box is a no-brainer it's the
best meat ship right to my door which
means one less trip to the groceries
because I don't want to have to go do
stuff so it's the most affordable and
convenient way to get healthy humanely
raised meet with butcher box you get the
highest quality meat around for just six
dollars a meal and even a free shipping
nationwide except Alaska and Hawaii
right now you can get two pounds of
ground beef and two packs of bacon
absolutely free plus $20 off your first
box just go to butcher box com /
Congrats or use promo code Congrats that
checkout that's butcher box com /
checkout bulla and branch
I love bullet and branch sheets because
when I'm sleeping I'm never too cold or
too hot even when I wake up in the
middle of the night they're the softest
and most comfortable sheets in the world
and the only bedding loved by three US
president that presidents that's Richard
Nixon Martin Van Buren and Barack Obama
is kidding that's not true for a limited
time you can get their luxury
flannel bedding to keep you cool
sleepers warm and to keep it cool
slippers warm and because they breathe
keep warm super cool it's really great
it's actually it's actually really kind
of fascinating how it is so you you if
you need a sheets get these woolen
bridge while you're there you can check
out all the other amazing stuff at
Boleyn branch like their mattress towel
the mattress is towels and much more
shipping is always free you can try them
out for 30 nights risk-free and right
now you get $50 off your first set of
sheets at Boleyn branch comm with promo
code Congrats get $50 off at Boleyn
branch comm promo code Congrats
that spelled bol L it's bol L and branch
comm code Congrats
congratulations is brought to you by
cash at the official app of the log
cabin dude there's something else I want
to talk about that I've been thinking
about for [ __ ] week and a half uh and
I cannot [ __ ] believe that this is a
real person I can't believe I haven't
known that until now this guy's name is
orange Cassidy and I tweeted about him I
said how did I not know this guy was
around I will follow him now to the ends
of the earth and I will dude he's the
best wrestler I've ever seen no offense
to Dave Batista because I really love
Dave but this guy is [ __ ]
unbelievable dude whether dark orders
Vic gonna play this video these guys are
out of the ring they're all been paying
and the lights go out and it just what
the [ __ ] is going the dark orders
playbook and now the lights come back on
and there's this guy standing with
jean jacket jeans on the jean jacket
open aviator sunglasses kneepads under
his jeans and you can see because they
rip because he is out set the [ __ ] he's
got a little bit of a beard bounces off
one rope da hands in his pockets dives
through the ring and hits the guys on
the outside of the ring and gets up
[ __ ] sunglasses are still on and
sauntering back into the thing still
puck is missing and gets up kick flips
oh the shakes
okay well dude this what I saw that I
couldn't believe it I laughed so hard
all right and now he is my favorite
wrestler and I will right I will be on
his team
dude you understand or whatever the [ __ ]
he wants honestly so I wrote that on
Twitter and then so many so many
articles were written of like wrestling
articles I was like Chris D'Elia
discovers orange cassadee cassadee or
whatever and I would like to go on a
[ __ ] record as discovering orange
Cassidy wow it was just so funny to me
I mean bro this is why it's so great
okay
everyone knows wrestling is fake and who
cares whatever that's not good or bad at
wrestling is ridiculous
this guy hmm is so dope figured out how
to be so cool but also is poking fun at
the wrestling world while wrestling
that [ __ ] is next-level that's why I
like him so much
because he's like oh you thought
wrestling was ridiculous check out if I
don't use my hands and keep it real
saucy
that's the coolest [ __ ] and he's
inspiring and there you have it dude
look up the video I'm not saying any
more about it because it's disrespectful
to even talk about it because you have
to see it so TI checks his daughter's
hymen every year haiti i straight up
real quick you're [ __ ] crazy
here's the thing dude you obviously
heard the story where TI was on the
podcast and he says after his birthday
his daughter's birthday he always goes
to the gynecologist and has the
gynecologist check her hymen to make
sure she's still a virgin
so okay that deserves a good TI chill
man
let your [ __ ] daughter do what she
wants when the sexual department she's
18 okay second of all dude uh don't tell
everyone that you do that because now
your daughter has to deal with the
[ __ ] blowback and aftermath and she's
getting made fun of dude well imagine
the supreme ass you got to be to be like
yeah I checked my daughter's hymen every
year how old is she 18 we did at her
birthday oh really yup and now have fun
dealing with that daughter I'm one of
the most famous rapper
oh my god dude I would have [ __ ]
moved out immediately right then I can't
believe he did that and then he of
course did he apologize no right can't
apologize as a rapper which is so
annoying
what a [ __ ] lunatic dude so sad
actually uh but [ __ ] shout out to
that girl man sorry sorry about that
that's cool I'm sure she's a [ __ ]
sweet girl man that sucks that he does
that and and it what really sucks is
telling everybody about it
like I just said it's just like dude hey
man weird as [ __ ] and then apparently
was on another podcast with his other
son talking about and he was like 14 and
the son are not a podcast but like a
show and his son was like talking about
like yeah and he was talking about a son
like yeah you know he hasn't lost his
virginity yet but it's coming you know
haha like dude ah sir
sexist SS patriarchy ti you know t TI
it's the [ __ ] only rapper you can
google you googled TI and they're like
are you not done with the word though
right
i went to i can't believe i'm talked
about this i meant to talk about this on
the podcast ever since i started i was
gonna talk you know but i this is where
the reason i I didn't forget about it
it's just the special went so well after
it that I started think about the
special lot but I my I met Eminem we
hung out for two hours and it was
[ __ ] unbelievable yeah you don't know
this so yeah dude my agents and him were
and them they're eight people were going
back and forth and they were like Chris
is gonna be in Detroit does em want to
come to the show and they're like yeah
definitely and then they were in New
York and so they were like why don't
wasn't Chris just come by the studio
when we land so they were in the studio
and my klonoa and Zach are like I'm up
on me I was always a huge Eminem fan
I mean all that [ __ ] but Mike Eminem was
Mike's Idol and still is and so Mike's
like oh my god I'm gonna [ __ ] talk
about all week so annoying I was like
maybe I shouldn't have invited you he's
like I'll be fine I'll be fine so we get
there and Zach and and we get in there
and we and we show up at Eminem's just
sitting there like come on it they come
on in and then I walk into the room and
and sitting there and Eminem stands up
and goes like this flapping around like
a babkin to me and I'm like okay this is
the craziest [ __ ] thing already he's
doing my impression to me of him and he
was like what's up man and then we sat
down and I'm sitting on the same couch
as Eminem and we're all talking and he
was like man you killed that impression
man it was so funny he was like it was
amazing and the one in the garage where
you're at where you're out of breath -
that's hilarious he's like cuz I get out
of breath sometimes I was just like it
was so mind-blowing and he is let me
just say this about him I sat with him
for two hours and in like 35 minutes and
I go I did the obligatory kind of like
nice guy like well we don't want to take
up too much your time like so and he was
the real like now we're just chill and
hang out like all right I said my
[ __ ] piece so we were hanging out and
he was talking about hip hop talking
about rap you know we can't we wanted to
obviously I I'm gonna do less of the
talking if I'm sitting with Eminem I
want him to do most of the talking and
and he was just in the best way in the
best way he was just the most normal
cool guy you know you don't know you
know these [ __ ] icons these legends
you know you meet them and sometimes
they have this air where it's like
you're you're lucky to be here dude he
didn't feel that way at I didn't feel
that way at all and was so cool and
refreshing he was just a real mature
kind of cool dude talked a lot about
hip-hop talked about a lot about who his
favorite rappers were and we talked
about comedy a lot we talked about
different comedians we talked about you
know my act what I'm talking about and
it was just a trip man but he mentioned
a bunch of his favorite rapper as you
mentioned you know I mentioned Tupac and
Biggie and jay-z and all those guys
but man it was I don't even know what to
say dude I kept thinking about it the
next day it was just so cool and then
they were like well let's get a picture
and we got a picture and I posted it to
Instagram and I was like dude I just
it's one thing that [ __ ] do this
thing in the in my in my driveway and
make this video and then I went viral
and it's nothing for you to share and
tweet it it's another thing for you to
put me on this song I was like but this
is so cool and it was just so nice you
to have us come in man it really means a
lot and I've always been such a big fan
of yours and he was like thank you man I
really appreciate it
I mean a so [ __ ] weird man
like I mean you know I meet everybody I
you know I meet everybody I mean I've
met [ __ ] everybody I like I met Jim
Carrey I've met [ __ ] all the you know
that was my idol when I was a kid Jim
Carrey and it's just like it's a trip
man to me it's kind of a trip to meet
somebody two out of the like I don't
really care about music but I know a lot
about hip hop and I love hip-hop and it
was cool to meet him because I I've
listened to his music so [ __ ] much
man so shout out to everyone who made
that happen Tracy over there too that
was kind of dealing with everything that
was Tracy's so sweet and all the other
guys that were over there to his tour
manager and then this other producer was
there too and my clean OG and Zach Tonko
via was there so what else happened to
what else was he there was one part
where he was like talking about some
somebody that was like talking [ __ ]
about him and he was talking to us in
conversation and Eminem was like you
don't even know what I'm doing when I'm
rapping and doing what we don't even
know what I'm doing when I'm rapping I'm
using syllables intricate Dib and he
started rapping in the middle of all he
was talking to us and it was [ __ ]
unbelievable dude I was like on the
couch with this guy and he's rapping
talking to me rapping telling me
something in a rap and it all made sense
it was [ __ ] insane it was such
imagine that dude being on the same
couch as Eminem I need you doing that
I was like whatever this life I have
this [ __ ] career that I've built out
of [ __ ] making dick jokes and yet I
mean just being silly and having a silly
goose time dude
and telling you [ __ ] live rips
and now I'm sitting on the couch with
the [ __ ] mmm and he's rapping to me
hey and he didn't even know that in the
Sprinter van on the way from [ __ ]
Pennsylvania to Detroit that I drank so
much coffee we had to pull over to the
side of road that I had to [ __ ] in
someone's yard he didn't even know that
and yes that happened a week ago bro in
the Sprinter van this is what happened
in the Sprinter van we're in the
Sprinter van we're driving and I go like
this all of a sudden I'm sitting there
and I'm chillin I'm like this is really
cool the seats recline and I'm chilling
I'm drinking my coffee and all of a
sudden my my [ __ ] stomach goes and
I'm like that's interesting man
anyway I so anyway guys yeah it isn't
that Mike's sleeping on my gays Atkins
acts like they and then all of a sudden
more and I'm like I have to focus going
on this weird man anyway so it's cool
we'll check out my phone Texan yeah it's
all good and that's funny I'm like I
think maybe we should and then knock on
the thing the divider and the thing goes
buddy that was me butters you're [ __ ]
in cell and the driver goes yeah and I
said amen um and I think about it and
I'm like maybe I don't and then and I'm
like you know what man you got a uh
maybe can you pull over we gotta find a
bathroom it's like okay sure man next
one that's like are cool we're still on
a freeway another model goes by it
there's no [ __ ] exit but hey man we
got to do that now and it was like yeah
I know I'm getting off now so he gets
off great and we're gonna make it and
there is a thing when you get a get off
on the freeway there's the right and the
left and on the right there's a hospital
and on the left there's another sign
that says something a mile away and he
takes a left and I get mad because I'm
thinking good hospitals have bathrooms
but he was thinking gas stations have
bathrooms so when he took the left my
sphincter went like this and I thought
hey man what was a thing there and he
goes yeah well I said there's a gas
station
and I go like this hey man pull over
right now and he says okay pulls over in
someone's yard there were a bunch of
trees hidden and I ran out took down my
new keith sweat pants squatted and
[ __ ] did my business and took the
Kleenex from the Sprinter van and did my
business there that way too and then I
had enough Kleenex wiped got back in the
Sprinter van and used the used the hand
sanitizer and the first thing I said was
damn they're gonna think they have a
mountain lion problem so I don't know
whose house that was but Crystal Leah
[ __ ] in your yard wherever that was
if you see that it wasn't a mountain
lion it was a [ __ ] comedian it was a
comedian and it was it was and I felt
[ __ ] amazing afterwards do it oh man
how about when you go win the [ __ ] and
you just like up here we go did I ever
tell you about the time I went to New
York and I [ __ ] know there was no
toilet paper oh no III bye I took it I
took it I took the one fire second who
brought the toilet paper out to you no I
took it before I left the Sprinter van
bro I take all my [ __ ] supplies
anyway did you see the did I tell you
about the time I went to the bath I'll
save it for another podcast we're
already over an hour but man that one
was I should actually want me to write
that now I'm gonna write that now so I
don't forget it for next time oh man
myself [ __ ] myself at the Soho grand
okay cool
all right guys that's your teaser for
tomorrow um have a good one dude you
guys life rips don't forget to [ __ ] go
the restock is gonna happen soon life
rips shirt life rip studies because
there's a layer of different layers of
life's ribbons
download the cash app for free in the
App Store or Google Play market text me
at eight one eight two three nine seven
oh eight seven
I texted I'll try text you back man I
got so many people texting me but
support the show by buying the merch
yeah all that stuff and subscribe to the
YouTube channel channel please and rate
and review it on iTunes it really helps
subscribe to the YouTube channel and I
got my new special coming out sometime
soon oh and you is coming out December
26th I posted an Instagram about that a
lot of people think it's a joke because
it's a thriller and I'm in it but a
minute I'm in the new episode the new
season of you which is really cool I
can't wait to do that and have you
checked that out see what happens with
me and you
it's very frilly see you guys
[Music]